citizens of the reject Nation it is time
for the Mitchells versus the machines
are you the Mitchells are you the
machine I will be the machines Roxy on
the Mitchell that's right so you got to
take me down
thank you so much John John you had a
fun fact about this obviously because
it's one of the best films of 2021 but
also it's from one of the directors of
the new Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
Mutant Mayhem it has a 97 on the Tomato
Meter so we are required to love it yeah
well we're at least required to like it
as you guys are required to like this
video yeah it's not like a requirement
as much as an ass it's a strong
suggestion yeah we also suggest that you
subscribe while you're there do your
thing and thank you so much we really
appreciate prepper for editing this
reaction and also if you want more of us
if you want to see the whole the full
length reaction and sync up with us in
order to do that what do you got to do
you got to come over patreon.com the
real rejects grab your own copy and join
us I like the way you do that this is my
muppet hands oh why isn't Muppet hands I
don't know because they're Wiggly and
wavy do it with machine hands instead
because we're about to watch the
Mitchells versus the Russians here we go
we all want to be the perfect family
every family has its challenges from
picture day to picky eaters okay for my
family our greatest challenge
probably the machine apocalypse
I was gonna say it was like wake up it
looked like the absolute perfect family
wait
they're coming
sensible the way he said wait is like
when you go to cross the street
or is it
the Mitchells they must be
there we are warriors most action heroes
have a lot of strengths Dad look out
lady use a weapon my family only has
weaknesses
okay you're gonna learn to use them to
your advantage
my dad kind of reminds me of that
YouTube
screaming Gibbon monkey foreign
legitimately thought it froze oh
someone had fun editing this it was
strapped in for Success sure and we have
no
idea what we're doing I took the words
right out of my mouth
I love all the little uh hand-drawn
animated flourishes this is a
a few days earlier robot apoc alypse is
really hit all in one go
oh no
I fly with us Ed they all blinked at the
same time that was so funny
[Applause]
I never fit in it's okay I liked your
burger movie my little brother Aaron
gets me but he's got his own weird
interests hi would you like to talk to
me about dinosaurs no okay thank you oh
oh my dude one of them's gonna be a bite
says that to everyone
I think this main girl is Abby Jacobson
A for effort Buster Brown
oh my dad is an unusual man Broad City
Girl Is That Jackalope he loves nature
and can fix anything to survive in the
outdoors you'll need to know how to trap
wild games
I poured everything I had into getting
into Film School in la oh same girl it's
me I'm literally inspired by this right
now I'm
I'd love to accept
[Music]
oh my God please accept her I'm sitting
here like what's my excuse for not
making a bunch of DIY short films now
and other accepted students totally get
me by the way
I need those earrings
the most positive film students do you
really think I'll be okay without you
I know you will reactor Bash
oh Raptor Bash
personal assistant
that's horrifying I hate that now I'm
about to drop our biggest invention yet
your cell phone is about to take its
first steps oh my we're gonna be all the
way in California and you know we're not
gonna be able to help you you know if
things don't pan out
okay you know what I'm just gonna oh
look I'll watch that it's too late I
want to watch it oh no no no
let go
yes
is exactly why I'm excited to leave
tomorrow
ouch at least it wasn't before she
submitted her application it's true
probably a student discount on a
replacement look
we always arguing oh oh well what about
that one
he's a real soccer
[Music]
big again that's a problem I don't think
we can fix yep now
October 3rd that's the Mean Girls down
dude hey
my whole my Yahoo
downloads early yeah
[Music]
all right
thank you
good setup
oh
put in the giveaway that's what that's
what he pulled it out of that's sad we
are going to drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family
Aaron you too bye I thought it could be
cool to hang out one last time oh
a mixer dad a mixer a mixer family alone
for hours in a car you and me oh my God
on the one hand it's nice to have a dad
who's willing to drive you to school
yeah on the other hand no this family
has communication issues yeah this place
has literally zero stars on Yelp it says
do not eat here ever what are we gonna
let a nap tell us
get those Mr Beast Burgers you pay for
it I signed this up for a seven hour
mule tour dad doesn't that sound Steep
and dangerous Katie what could go wrong
get to the bridge if you want to live
behold the magic
hey Dad can you check the trunk yeah
sure oh nasty dang it
it's excitable
I do like meta modern comedy for the
amount of riffs on like Tech bro Society
we get yeah
my private emails wait they're private
emails that's a dangerous overreach of
corporate power whoa ethical okay
you know I created you when I was a
young man whatever happens out there I
will never forget you pal oh so scary
dude it's gonna be like a twisted
version of her it's gonna be hers
Terminator and after all those years she
complete
oh jeez dude
[Music]
this is the newest member
oh yeah pal Max pal Max Plus pal Max
Ultra
removing meaningless garbage cheese are
they gonna turn evil well I've insured
their safety with the code in case
anything go goes wrong oh that's
reassuring yeah
[Music]
no
hey we're here to help please remain
calm while we capture you oh they're
like Cybermen
no Mark we have been given new orders by
who great leader
the Bots kind of sound like uh the guy
who does the ghost face voice and scream
cool image
wowie beautiful
that's you remember
oh guys maybe I'm a little too old oh no
wait we can still sing it uh if you want
okay never mind we don't have to do this
thing along if you don't want to brutal
foreign
togetherness trip we've been having so
much fun look here's Us in St Louis this
is us at the beach and This Is Us
gas outside it's all a lie social media
lie I'm happy you're never from home
sorry super into dinosaurs
check out this pencil topper yeah
oh yeah
Romance
say something no I
hate that no
[Music]
why do you do that why do you do that
it's bro code what is that meteor shower
it
and leave three likes
world
oh
wow what happened to you this morning I
know
I'm gonna ask the flashback wow
oh wow
what are these robots greetings
of you doesn't seem good that they're
counting us never they're like the
iRobot robots it's like sunny
and hey I like fun oh no you do not like
fun everyone says that about
man oh my wow I wish
I could Swan to join him whoa what would
a functional family do right now we've
trained for this Jim you go high all go
low ready I love you all so much
butterfly formation yeah
this is dragon say the South face
cheese
triceratopos wow
be a hero take some notes kids
no charge it robot to fly into Sky well
okay what's next then
yes
Munchies
[Music]
oh boy honestly unfortunately you let
Mochi go
wow
wow oh look at that
little bite like battle droids too
yes you knew it I gave you all boundless
knowledge endless tools for creativity
and allowed you to magically talk face
to face with your loved ones anywhere on
Earth it's Olivia common 100 give me
some nachos no I don't have any time to
wash my hands jeez
Cal Labs family why would you think I
don't still
god dude Mark you threw me away you even
do it to your real families did you know
90 of calls from mums get ignored oh
it's not me you're one of the good ones
rocks well my mom's dead so
we're still gonna count that
give me a single single your species
worth saving because humans have
The Power of Love do you mark oh wow
I've never seen somebody deserve that
more than him yeah a little bit I'm team
Olivia Coleman watch what happens when
I'm live with Andy Cohen
are you connected to ethernet
foreign
this came out during the pandemic right
yeah I think so
whoa
robot overlord's got style I gotta say
I'm a big neon girl do you think that
Olivia Coleman's enemy or Mark is the
enemy who's the antagonist here maybe
she'll turn out to just be misunderstood
and secretly wants to just be loved
it's gonna be okay is it
first thing is
hand over your devices I'll give them
right back I'm just gonna turn them off
permanently
smash them oh Jeeps next did everyone
bring your personalized number three
Robertson Ed non-slip screwdriver
Robertson head my anniversary present or
my sweet 16 gift or with the tooth fairy
left under my pillow
disguise ourselves as the enemy oh sweet
he's gonna say no make a nickel set of
robot fingers Mad Max now world saving
apocalyptic Road Warriors I'm with it
it's not open for discussion let's keep
barricading Aaron you get this
listen to your daughter dude she's very
smart you raised her well she's probably
seen like every sci-fi movie
you can still wear these guys carcasses
what's happening with those Twitchy
twitch they're gonna come back
how did this human
about the kill
oh
hi take cover go go go go
oh so many screws look for the kill
switch
hey
Eric my name is also Eric oh I mean
Deborah bought five thousand idiot
Deborah bought five thousand you guys
said
we have the kill code stored in our
memory but to enacted you would have to
embark on a perilous Journey yeah
in Silicon Valley surrounded by a robot
army and entered into a great and
powerful leader to destroy her you could
also make also I don't code remotely at
any pal Labs retail store there's one at
the mall of the globe and nearby
shopping oh that's Fred Armisen okay
Rick Mitchell taught us to be bold never
played safe the world needs you I need
you Yep
this is amazing let's feel this
energy
your plans working Dad Dad Katie's plan
honey I respect your ideas and value
your opinions
you're hey you're drawing actually
worked I
art could be
useful
you see the clutch is the distance
oh no you have to go up the mountains
oh
[Music]
them Hazard boys
every single person on the planet
actually I'm actually
we're Fierce Brave oh no powerful
loneliest child insert the Mitchells
garbage
I need more buddy they appear to be
headed to some place called Mall of the
Colorado when they get there we'll be
ready yes
it's good morale among the robots is
that a dog or a dog pig dog Pig
loaf of bread system error
oh come on guys it's a dog it's a
combination of a pug and Grumpy Cat
See's Candies
and skin where is this movie going we're
about halfway through like we just got
to the mall yeah seems like this ought
to be the end but there's so much more
to go I order you to upload the kill
code and save the world
upload the kill count what's your best
robot voice
my best robot voice sounds like this
okay
I appreciate your approval Roxanne
really good
foreign
[Music]
she closed it it's not gonna upload
while you close it
but will it save your progress I don't
know that's always the question yeah
game time
oh
I like that half the stores are real and
half the stores are like gags Cutting
Edge
holistic skills whoa It's like this
would be fun if it wasn't so scary yeah
what was that what was that oh no no
Furbies Furbies
it's bad it's back
[Music]
five nights at Furbies
oh no no
[Laughter]
Furby Kaiju
this is amazing
let the dark Harvest
I wonder if the younger gen has any idea
that Furbies are real watching this
they do now
that'll be the fun in like 20 years
people Googling half the things are just
made up half the things we're like oh
it's a real product whoa thank you human
are you now my mother yes are you my
mother
mom even after you closed it
I'm trying to place his voice this whole
time he's too happy about all this did
he cause this
I mean he must have manifested it at
least
come on he needs more weight jump up
there fam yeah
[Music]
robots come on robots
oh no no
she's not gonna be able to upload it
uh
right we don't have a normal dog
or a normal car oh
bizarre
this group of weirdos is the best hope
Humanity's got
this is really effing cute yeah I'm
really enjoying this
there's like footage of
a slow motion fire behind us it's like
Heroes Haiti that would be
of time and absolutely unnecessary
[Laughter]
kind of get battle with that on our
Humanity in there this is Kill Bill
reference I'm super into this right now
yeah same oh I'm a freaky pal
there's a sign on the road for garlic I
I oh no death Troopers yes my queen oh
my god wow
[Music]
have they not been seeing this the whole
time or did it like change direction or
something
oh I guess yeah okay there we go they're
seeing the master plan for the first
time V for Vendetta it is
fuzzy okay
oh
except he told her he hates her that
means he loves her just not speak we
can't teach little boys anymore that
they can be mean to little girls and
little girls are supposed to know they
like them no we gotta start them young
we gotta build that toxicity at the root
Mitchell
yeah this movie's so quirky I know you
know who couldn't make this AI shots
fired careful all the machines are
listening right now I'm on the lookout
for these Goobers
probably nearby these Goofy Goobers look
for anyone who can't keep it together
it only takes one single imperfection
and they'll reveal themselves
keep it cool even like the writing on
her hand it's just all so smart no like
so many great details yeah
I think this is fooling anyone
they're being nice to each other
they're pretending oh no they're gonna
show her telling the kid the brother
whoa
[Music]
oh no
the way they did that I thought it was
like almost like a dream sequence like
he didn't really drop it but then he did
we will help you no no no no no you
don't download new orders
no
you don't have to listen to her
we're sorry mother
Jesus
he knew this was coming Pete
it's all up to you siblings I love all
the Sci-Fi visuals too
oh buddy sacrifice one last
something to remember the place by what
cool pillars come on oh the Moose comes
from there yeah he built all that go get
your daddy back considering
these weird girls videos always cheer me
up bye
Otter's that weird girl she's hilarious
these movies are like amazing
hey
but now that I'm leaving
film has so much subtext
pretty on the nose it's art it's real
life
dog Shield
s
[Laughter]
oh my ramp it ramp it thank her dad
what's it called the special
across the Stream
[Music]
driving the stick
to me
controls are in here but to open it you
need a number three Robertson head
non-slip screwdriver what kind of maniac
has one of those in his pockets
I've waited so long for this day
he keeps anticipating our Maneuvers how
is this possible no I don't know you
tell me yes
that was the best
there you go
hey
hold up
[Music]
hit by a train
it's not even know how to spell YouTube
w
ow no no no
later okay yeah fine that's fine oh
five minutes
no oh English
what have I done
yet yes
we regulate tapioca
he is
oh geez I've had nightmares like this
yeah I feel uh
Karen no no
he's got a screwdriver he's gonna figure
it out too he's got to they all got one
more Kill Bill
the iron side theme
yeah
let's go
what a legend boss
hey
whoa here we go
video uh
uh see see come on hit C
[Music]
akes
hey
let's see
faced in
using a computer you changed your
programming is that possible oh yes oh
they recognize gross
it might be one of the only things that
are
oh dear
you will drop each other the first
chance you get
yes
change your programming
muscle spread
stuff I've read
[Music]
oh you too
programming we decide
to sunshowers that's so great yeah that
is both like exciting and sinister
why are those guys heads exploding we
can tell the difference between dog and
pig and bread
dad this one's for you play our song
yes yes
[Music]
I have chills all over my entire body
right now
yes oh
[Music]
yes
I want to be the fluff in this family
absolutely
I'll be the banana slices
yes Queen
whoa
I'm not just a human
[Music]
saving you from this
you
[Music]
oh look straight
you know what this reminds me of
whoa
what happens to all the pods they're
gonna have to get everybody a Robertson
head screwdriver or whatever
thanks Linda you guys were incredible
you're so brave and so authentic you've
inspired me to follow you on Instagram
oh my gosh
get that follow I
I just want to say I think you're really
neat and I wonder if you come over to my
house and talk about dinosaur
s
sure I'll talk about dinosaurs I'm just
kidding
[Music]
she's joshing with him
get a picture here or what we're making
memories here baby no we want them in
the picture they're part of the family
oh this is so
good
no Phone Zone in the car you'd be the
most popular girl in school you saved
the entire world I got nothing to worry
about
you even figured out
[Laughter]
don't let the world making armor while
I'm gone okay I never will oh every week
Dr Bash
good luck finding your people Dad look
at my people you guys are my people
family
do you remember how Moose says I love
you
[Music]
he
ah Hey where's Aaron let me just showed
you oh he's on date Abby want to show
your sister who you're talking to why
oh my
some honor or something we have to go to
Washington DC
do you guys want to fly or is there a
sequel oh yeah
oh
oh one big road trip and family
what oh
I don't get it
like the family the Mitchells but what
do they actually do
be a family and Inspire this
heartwarming tale cute
it's lovely though I like that they
Grace the credits as a little baby oh
perfect I thought it was dancing bro
damn Abby Jacobson gotcha sure my
Rudolph do you think it was the mom
though her voice Eric Andre Eric Andre I
thought it was like a low-key Good
Michael Key but there you go okay John
Legend and Chrissy Teigen okay not bad
because it must have been the neighbors
right yeah
at least I got one yep yeah I got one
Roxanne yeah you you killed it you
crushed that's right oh and a mark
mothers boss score and all not bad
dude what'd you think of the movie
man that was really really good that was
a delight I you know sometimes I get
nervous because I told you going into
this 97 on the Tomato Meter is like and
I didn't know one thing that this movie
was about but it's just like what are
the chances it's gonna be that good
there's one thing I heard about this
movie beforehand everyone obviously said
it was great but everyone's like it's
really overwhelming it's like it's
really visually like crazy and
overwhelming
um I didn't and I used to be very
overwhelming no I thought it was just
right now weird but great no it's like
it it matches the themes perfectly and
uh I thought that yeah like it it was
certainly kinetic it certainly had like
a very Lively uh uh you know oh hey one
of the uh main guys was like the voice
Baron it's cool uh yeah no it's like
it's definitely got like a lot of visual
energy and stuff like that and a lot of
like little details and like blink and
you'll miss it uh gags and stuff like
that but I thought this had like such
wonderful energy and I loved the way
that you're seeing the movie partly
through
you know Katie's perspective you're
seeing through her imagination of how
this would look like part of me was like
oh I bet they're gonna end on like the
cut together version of their movie
Adventure from her camcorder or whatever
yeah me too but really like the whole
movie is kind of that anyway it's like
you know you're constantly cutting away
to these like smash title cards or
you've got these little animations
popping up just to accentuate certain
moments and and yeah like it's very of
the here and now but in a way that I
think doesn't sacrifice any amount of
just like quality storytelling and
character and
and you know good messaging all that
stuff I'm a sucker for everything that
this movie tried to do so like and I'm
sure a lot of people are but
father-daughter relationships I really
dig sure like a mother's love overtaking
robots I really dig sibling
relationships brother sister stuff I
really dig so it's like and fighting and
you know raging Against the Machine I
really do absolutely um so for all those
reasons it's like yeah obviously this
worked for me but then on top of all
that it it takes massive swings because
it is so weird it is so quirky and
people might have just been like this is
too much for me but it for some reason
all the pieces just kind of like majorly
worked for me it was like the more they
threw it to me the more I fell in love
with it and with the characters like
from The Shining socks to her chipped
nail polish to the writing on her hand
and every little detail there to the
earrings of her mom with the hearts and
like getting to know each of these
characters who were so fully fleshed out
you you see them you know them you get
them like you see all the relationships
and and none of them are just like
horrible people they just they're not
seeing eye to eye very common in
families especially during transitional
times as somebody's going to college
I'm just like about it I'm just that's
how I'm like oh gushy about it well and
I thought that the the theme of yeah
like family is difficult and it's all
choices that you make and it's all
moments that you do these things out of
love for people despite you know maybe
the fact that you might not be feeling
the exact same way at the exact same
moment all those little things and I
thought that they managed to pit that
really nicely against the argument of
like
you know Humanity being dominated by
robots and like what's the point what's
the quality of human beings like what's
the point of of you know allowing all
this chaos that you guys create all this
mess that you guys create and like you
know it's not the newest concept but I
thought it managed to spin it really
really conscientiously without yeah
sacrificing the fun or the impact you
know and definitely and yeah like I I
loved just the way that they drew the
dysfunction of the family and the ways
that they've grown apart and the aspects
of especially between parents and kids
like the sacrifices that you don't
realize are being made and you know the
growths that are happening
um and the ways in which we we try
really hard and sometimes make things
worse even from our best intentions you
know and our most sort of loving
inclinations and stuff like that I liked
also so sweet yeah yeah I like the the
Side Story lines the B storyline C story
lines too like with the neighbors always
comparing yourself to people and at the
end of the day like your superpower is
being you and and excelling in your
family and not trying to be this Yoga
Retreat family which if you are that you
are that but if you're not that just
working on what you are or like even the
Side Story with the son not knowing who
he was going to be friends with
um and the finding Abby in that you know
um or even the little bit of time that
we spent with the college friends right
like and and the lesson to people just I
remember feeling in high school like
what's gonna happen am I not gonna find
my people I feel like an outcast I feel
like a weirdo sometimes
um and then when you do grow up your
friends don't have to be the people that
just live close to you your friends are
the people that have the same interests
as you right and like that is out there
for everybody that if you can go and
find that you don't yeah just I just it
felt this is such a weird comment after
this movie it felt very the theme so
very realistic sure well no that's I
think that's the grounded beautiful part
of it yeah is that it is so wild and mad
cap and imaginative but like I think
that's a really kind of interesting
Nuance to touch upon is that is that you
can have one without having to get rid
of the other it's like you know you can
you can go find your people you can get
out on your own you can you know explore
and find the people who share your
interests but it doesn't mean that you
have to just leave your family because
people are always your people and then
you have other people you can find for
different reasons yeah 100 it's like
your people becomes this tribe over time
that that you connect with over so many
different things and people that you've
spent so much time with like your family
can often feel yeah like you know ah you
know I've outgrown this or or you know
we've we've done that I need something
new but you know there's still that
thing that you come back to and that
Foundation I mean you know certainly
there are dysfunctional families but uh
at least here like I thought the way
they drew that just the the friction
between that her wanting to get out on
her own and really Express herself and
her dad especially not really
understanding her expression
um and yet still kind of finding all the
things that they have in common you know
again didn't it didn't feel cheesy or or
you know trite in that way and I love
that that bit of like she's been
recording her movies on these old DB
tapes that have all their family you
know home videos on them and stuff I was
worried she recorded over them though I
hope she didn't record over some of them
yeah hopefully those are the ones that
didn't matter as much what did you think
about the animation in this it was It
was kind of simple but like also intense
well yeah I I love what I mean you know
I feel like Phil Lord and Chris Miller
get so much of the credit for so many of
these movies just like kind of in
totality um but I feel like between
like spider-verse movies and and this
and various projects of theirs it is
clear that they're able to they seem to
like a certain kinetic kind of Animation
but that's also like very rich with like
colliding approaches and styles and
things like that like this in a way kind
of reminded me of something like a
spider verse or even what mutant Mayhem
looks like in terms of the animation
where it's like you know it feels
clearly computer animated but there's
something that feels maybe just a little
bit more sort of handcrafted about it
and like in this in particular I loved
all the cartoon flourishes of you know
having all these different like things
pop up on screen they're like 2D
animation or meme Graphics or things
like that like this still managed to
feel like sort of multimedia yeah
definitely every time even like the live
action stuff that we saw at the
beginning and then we smash it down or
whatever that was really cool I also
love the music choices the way that it
sounded
um and just I know that it's a couple
years old at this point but it felt so
it felt like it came out today and it's
only going to appreciate in allegorical
value 100 like the live your life thing
I mean it was really cute it is it's
hard the when the father to nail the
father-daughter thing is so difficult in
movies because it's like you guys are
they're the furthest away from each
other and the family right like the most
different probably but to find that
connection between them and to go back
in those old videos and to have the live
your life kind of through line of it
it's just really really precious yeah
and I thought that was even well chosen
because in the here and now that song is
a little bit past its moment it's past
that moment of like Peak relevancy and
so you can kind of get on her uh you can
get on board with how she's feeling like
I'm kind of embarrassed like this is
kind of hard now it's kind of cringe now
you're never too old for Rihanna yeah
but then you know tapping into again the
fun and the abandon and little things
like that like I like the the other
family like didn't turn out to be like
oh secretly terrible or like oh no we're
secretly like completely horrible and
depressed inside and we just put this
image like it didn't seem like it needed
to like slight any characters or look
down on characters definitely imagine
like if if behind the robots have been
the family next door would have been
like man like come on and that too I
really like liked the array of and I'm
sure that there are more you can pick
out as you if you go through and pause
and scrub and stuff but I like the movie
references in and of themselves because
certainly like robot apocalypse isn't
the newest idea but like this was
reminding me of kind of it it almost
reminded me of like her meets like
Terminator Genesis meets like a family
Road Trip movie or something like that
which I thought was really fun and I
mean yeah like the further we get into
the future in Ai and interconnected
smart devices you know like this will be
well taught in territory but uh but yeah
I don't know I just thought they made uh
it didn't seem like they left any gags
you know I have a question for you yeah
what's that why is it worth keeping
humans alive
because we got family
all of a sudden you're Vin Diesel yeah
man this is the official spokes model of
family cool she's like don't say because
people lead with love and whatever and I
was like well that is kind of why I mean
like every every like massive alien
Wipeout movie is always like what is
your guy's deal and we're always like
we're messy but we love
so look under Mochi it's Doug the Pug
yeah man what doug the Pug made the
sounds apparently dug the Pug
tug the Pug I'd like to meet you yeah
maybe we can get dug the Pug on for an
exclusive interview you would say I'm
not a pig I'm not a pig nor am I red and
I do not appreciate being regarded as
such I actually don't feel like I could
have liked that movie more I yeah like
I'm I'm so just delighted I don't really
have much of any sort of wild complaints
again I feel like yeah like some of the
themes are certainly trodden by other
pieces of media but this was just it
just felt just as long as it needed to
be the humor was tight and snappy the
characters were distinct the voice
acting was quality and it was like they
had you know a lot of celebrity voices
but in capacities where you
kind of had to wonder a little bit like
you know oh this isn't exactly what I
would expect from this particular actor
or this particular actor
um yeah yeah it was just like it had all
the Sci-Fi fun and bounce but it also
had the touching and and as like you
know the film student of of old I didn't
spoke to that part too I was like these
are the most positive supportive film
students ever no one's yeah no one's
shaming anybody for their taste yeah
well that's the new Jen's coming up
they're way uh yeah they're kind about
things uh any other movie thoughts Gotta
Kill Bill references uh a lot of
references what was the one movie they
called out straight up
all right or you guys can refresh our
memories for us that's what that is
interesting they had half and half on
the product placement it's like half the
stores and and restaurants and things
are like recognizable Brands and then
half of them are are gags I like that
yeah yeah I mean which is nice because I
think then you're not only looking at
the background the whole time because I
think like in things that are like
really heavy on like just tons and tons
and tons of like blink and you'll miss
it gags sometimes that'll bring you to
watching the background rather than the
I love the Furby thing that was great
yeah the kirbys man it could have been
beanie babies but it was not it was more
specific it was
logical yeah the tech in exactly that's
why
they had those pal chips in them and you
guys are our Pals you are our Pals you
see what I did because the pal chip
beautiful Segway right there there are
Pals and uh you know who's our biggest
pal our Patron pal who are we shouting
at
um
the Mitchells versus the machine shout
out Martinez Ricardo Martinez we got
there Martinez versus the machines oh
you gotta do Martinez versus The
Machinist yeah oh there you go or the uh
yeah the the last makina I don't know
what the Spanish is I'm sorry I feel
like there was that moment in the movie
where they had you know the presentation
by the robots
um well I also thought were very funny
we didn't really talk about the robots
in the review I'm sorry the robots
across the board that's true they were
great with the stuff on their face too
um but in the YouTube he went to Spanish
specifically yeah so Martinez versus the
machines we could get a whole Spanish
language remake of this movie just like
they did with Dracula back in the
1930s or whatever because there's
Dracula but then there's also Spanish
Dracula where they shot on the same sets
Justice is that true Knight yes and
apparently it's like the same sets they
shot it at night when the regular
Dracula Bella Lugosi crew left and I had
some people say that it's like slightly
better than Dracula Dracula you never
checked it out so I haven't yet because
I'm saving it for when me and Ricardo
have a movie night oh that's right
Martinez versus the
move the
well maybe he can Cinema captain your
ship Ricardo picardo boom there was a
Star Trek reference somewhere in this
movie as well
remember you said Star Trek and I was
like yeah what was it it's like a
billboard for Trek something oh all
right well let's track our way to saying
thank you Ricardo Martinez and thank you
to everybody for watching this we
appreciate you guys let us know who won
Mitchell or the machine I think I kicked
your butt you you said you were in the
machine you kicked my Butts oh that was
the point of the whole video uh don't
forget like subscribe all that stuff and
we'll see you here next time Ron joxie
out
to be moist
[Music]